chimè a créé un rayon de la mort une
soixantaine de bateaux Romains
s'approchaient de son inatal de Ccile
avec son invention de génie il les
aurait tous détruit mit tout réalité en
fait on a un peu exagéré fait ça serait
en fait un rayon de chaleur avec un nom
pimpé il aurait utilisé des miroirs pour
concentrer les rayons du soleil en un
seul point si chaud que les bateaux
auraient pris feu comme une grosse loupe
sur du papier quoi on a reproduit la
machine on l'a testé et ça marche avec
des miroir moderne en vert réflecteur à
l'époque on avait pas ça juste des
métopolis et le résultat est MOS 300 de
ces miroirs antiqu concentrés non réussi
à faire que de la fumée ça devait être
super difficile à manier il faut garder
le point de focus sur une cible en
mouvement jusqu'à ce qu'elle prenne feu
au mieux Archimède en a ébloui
quelques-uns et c'est les catapultes qui
ont fait le travail à moins que